نبدا معك عامر عن السفارات الانذار التي
دورت في كيف
نعم جلال منذ الساعه 8 تقريبا بتوقيت
المحلي بدء الصفرات الانذار تدوي في
العاصمه كاف ثم سمعنا اصوات انفجارات
تعديده في العاصمه اخر الاخبار تتحدث عن
تمكن من الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه من
اسقاط صاروخ في منطقه بوتشا الشهيره تذكر
في بدايه الحرب تلك التي يعني وصفت بانها
يعني حصلت فيها الكثير من المجازر هناك
بلديه هذه الناحيه التابعه لكيف قال بانه
تم اسقاط صاروخ بالقرب من هذه المدينه في
غرب العاصمه كيف ايضا عمده المدينه قال
بان هناك عده انفجارات في شرق العاصمه
كياف وان همم سيارات الاسعاف توجهت الى
تلك المنطقه نحن نحاول الوصول ايضا بدورنا
الى تلك المنطقه لكن لم نصل بعد لا يوجد
اي معلومات عن وقوع ضحايا لكن همم حاكم
المدينه تحدث عن ان هذه الصواريخ تستهدف
البنيه التحتيه في المدينه حضر المواطنين
من الخروج دعاهم الى اللجوء الى الملاجئ
عدم الخروج في انتظار تعليمات اخرى من
المسؤولين ومن السلطات الاوكرانيه اذا
جلال نحن نتحدث عن الاستهداف عن استمرار
مسلسل استهداف البنى التحتيه في العاصمه
كياب وفي مناطق اخرى طبعا للعلم هناك همم
وفقا لحاكم خارقيف سقطت ثلاث صواريخ
استهدفت مناطق مهمه على حد وصف حاكم خايف
لالبون التحتيه في هذه المدينه الواقعه
شمال شرق اوكرانيا ايضا في العديد من
المناطق في همم في في اوكرانيا المهم اذا
ان هذا المسلسل المستمر على الرغم من ان
السلطات الاوكرانيات تحذر وتحذر العالم من
اضرار ما يجري انعكاساته على العالم وليس
فقط على اوكرانيا بمعنى رئيسكي كان قد
تحدث بالامس واول امس تناول نفس الموضوع
قال عندما نفقد الطاقه الكهربائيه
والتدفئه وتصبح دولهنا ومدنا غير قابله
للحياه فان اوروبا قد تنتظر هجران كبيره
نحوها وهذا سيؤثر على امنها القومي
وبالتالي هو ذا العالم وداع اوروبا دعا
امس الاتحاد الاوروبي الى دعم اوكرانيا
توفير مضادات الدفاع الجوي التي تمكن
اوكرانيا من حمايه اجوائها وايضا دعاها
الى تزويدها بالطاقه تزويدها بالغاز لكي
تتمكن من توفير الطاقه لمواطنها وبالتالي
تمنع هذه الهجرات الجماعيه نحوها في نفس
الاطار ربما صباح اليوم كانت قد تحدثت
قياده القوات الجويه عن هذا الموضوع نعم
الوضع ليس كما كان عليه في بدايه الحرب
هذا وفقا للقياده القوات الجويه التي قالت
باننا في بدايه الحرب كنا قادرين على
اسقاط تقريبا 50% من الصواريخ التي تستهدف
المدن الاوكرانيه لكن الان مع التطور مع
الاسلحه التي وصلتنا اصبحنا قادرين على
استهداف 80% اي انها رفعت من قدرتها 30%
قدره اسقاط هذه الصواريخ لكن يقول وتقول
قياده اركاله الجويه ما زال هناك الكثير
لنعمله ما زال علينا ان نحسن ونقوي من هذه
القوى من هذه الدفاعات الجويه ودعوا
العالم الى دعم اوكرانيا
مواجهه ما وصف وما يصفه الاوكرانيين دائما
بالارهاب الصاروخ الذي يستهدف البنا
التحتيه لهذه الدوله في هذا الشتاء القارص
تعلم اوكرانيا من احدى اكثر الدول ربما
صعوبه من ناحيه الظروفها الجويه وبالتالي
مناشده للعالم بمساعده هذه الدوله لتوفير
الحمايه لسكان ابيض